[Musique]
il ya quelques mois je reçois un message
du go bizarrement c'est une citation de
darwin charles darwin les espèces qui
survivent ne sont pas les espèces les
plus fortes ni les plus intelligentes
mais celles qui s'adaptent le mieux aux
changements hockey entre nous j'ai rien
compris je leur ai pondu un emoji qui
sourient et là il me répond remplace
espèces par l'entreprise la situation
changeait alors les entreprises qui
survivent ne sont pas les plus fortes ni
les plus intelligentes mais celles qui
s'adaptent le mieux aux changements
d'accords très bien mais qu'est ce que
ça signifie s'adapter aux changements
pour françois et moi une entreprise qui
s'adaptent aux changements c'est une
entreprise qui est créative productive
qui s'est identifié et capter les
talents donc pour être productive et
créative
une entreprise doit s'efforcer de
recruter les meilleurs talents mais en
plus de les recruter
elle doit savoir les retenir les engager
les motiver d'ailleurs en parlant d'
engagement j'aimerais vous parler de
pierre pierre est un ami il vient tout
juste d'être diplômé il a été embauché
il ya récemment par l'entreprise de ses
rêves
il ya quelques temps je lui envoie un
message pour savoir comment se passe sa
nouvelle vie et là il me répond vivement
lé week end pierre à 25 ans c'est son
premier travail le travail de ses rêves
quand il dit à françois a vivement ce
week-end on est lundi en fin de matinée
véritable choc pour nous on se rend
compte qu'on ne veut vraiment pas vivre
la même situation qu'hier tout comme lui
nous sommes deux étudiants en école de
commerce et dans quelques mois nous
aurons à répondre à la question qu'on
nous pose depuis qu'on est tout
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard
question difficile pour y répondre on a
senti le besoin de voir autre chose de
rencontrer des personnes différentes de
d'apprendre de nous immerger dans les
entreprises aux profils variés
différents avec des missions disruptive
c'est pourquoi on est parti pendant six
mois six mois faire le tour du monde à
la rencontre des hommes et des hommes et
des femmes qui travaillent différemment
qui s'éloigne
tu es schéma classique de management des
entreprises des organisations qui
parviennent à engager leurs
collaborateurs à les impliquer à gagner
en créativité en productivité en pouvoir
d'innovation
cette aventure c'est le tour du monde
des baroudeurs de l'innovation
managériale
les baroudeurs de l'innovation
c'est deux étudiants 5 continents
quatorze pays une cinquantaine
d'entreprises visiter 173 jours de
voyage et des milliers de souvenirs avec
françois on est parti le 2 juillet on
est revenu le 23 décembre à la rencontre
de ces entreprises de ses managers qui
travaille différemment pour montrer à
pierre qu'ils existent et aux quatre
coins du monde
la première question qu'on s'est posée
c'est comment être sûr que l'entreprise
pour laquelle je travaille est la bonne
avec tout ce que cela implique
est-ce que je vais être la bonne
personne pour l'entreprise mais aussi
est-ce que je vais pouvoir m'épanouir
dans celle ci est ce que je vais pouvoir
évoluer au sein de cette entreprise
parmi toutes les entreprises qu'on a
rencontré deux d'entre elles illustrent
très bien cet exemple cette question
avec françois on est à phnom penh au
cambodge
on a rendez vous avec vieille dit à une
agence de marketing qui emploie une
trentaine de personnes via les noëls
fondateur nous reçoit il nous explique
sa méthode particulière pour recruter
les futurs collaborateurs
sinon votre avis chez vieille dia on
passe trois entretiens va passer un
entretien avec quelqu'un qui sera d'un
niveau hiérarchique supérieur au nôtre
on va passer un entretien avec un
collaborateur qui sera du même niveau
hiérarchique mais on voit aussi passer
un entretien avec quelqu'un qu'on sera
amené à manager cependant on sait pas
qui est qui ensuite les trois personnes
se retrouvent
elle se pose la question est-ce qu'on
emploie ou pas ce candidat s'ils sont
pas d'accord c'est la personne qui a le
niveau hiérarchique le plus bas qui sera
décisionnaire du coup quand on travaille
chez via le recrutement est légitime sa
poche la seconde entreprise voit les
choses totalement différemment pour ce
vendeur de chaussures en ligne de las
vegas l'important est d'avoir des
employés réellement en phase avec la
culture atypique de l'entreprise
pourquoi lors de la dernière étape de
recrutement on propose deux mille
dollars aux candidats pour qu'ils
refusent le travail ainsi si le candidat
accepte le travail et on tire un trait
sur ces deux mille dollars
c'est qu'il est certain d'être motivé
par les entreprises par le par le poste
et qui ne sera vraiment en phase avec la
culture d'entreprise
quant à l'entreprise est sûr que son
employé ne sera pas motivée uniquement
par l'argent mais aussi par sa mission
par son travail tout au quotidien le
recrutement c'est important mais ça fait
pas tout pierre nous dit qu'ils
accumulent les heures il rentrait tard
il dort peu ils arrivent tôt au bureau
le matin mais il sait pas il sait pas si
c'est les collaborateurs considèrent
qu'il fait du bon travail il se sait pas
comment se positionner dans l'entreprise
il ya un problème de reconnaissance avec
françois aujourd'hui on se dit qu'il
faudrait qu'on parle de deux entreprises
à pierre une qu'on a rencontrés au
vietnam et une autre qu'on a vu à rio au
brésil
là où la poste comptait plus de 1500
employés cyclo petite entreprise de
développement de logiciels situé au
vietnam on compte seulement une
vingtaine cyclo à une méthode bien à
elle pour reconnaître le travail de ses
employés
la distribution quotidienne de tacos ok
on ne parle pas de vers et acoss mais de
tacos virtuelle des emoji échanger sur
la discussion interne de l'entreprise
ainsi chaque jour tous les
collaborateurs la porte la possibilité
de distribuer jusqu'à trois tacos halak
à leurs collègues pour les remercier de
quelque chose en particulier pour une
aide sur un projet une attention
particulière
un travail bien réalisé une fois ces
tacots s'accumuler on peut les échanger
condé compte des objets pour améliorer
le quotidien au travail ou alors on peut
aussi s'en servir pour payer des
activités de team building a réalisé
avec ses collègues des tacos c'est bien
ça fait pas tout la reconnaissance peut
aussi passer par l'argent pour cela on a
vu une entreprise au brésil à rio qui
s'appelle daiichi labs qui s'est inspiré
de l'application de rencontres mobile
tender tous les quatre mois
chaque collaborateur de l'entreprise
il voit le visage des autres
collaborateurs défiler sept personnes
sweep à droite si elle estime que le
collaborateur doit gagner plus que lui à
gauche s'il estime qu'il doit gagner
moins à la fin un classement et créé en
fonction de la réponse de tous les
collaborateurs de ce classement est
indexé des primes pour toute
l'entreprise
par conséquent en fonction de ces primes
on sait où on se situe on sait comment
les collaborateurs juge notre travail et
on a une récompense financière pour
s'améliorer
pierre aurait aussi aimé qu'on la
compagne quand le guide qu'on lui fasse
des retours des conseils des critiques
constructives ce qu'on appelle
communément le feedback
alors ce qui concerne le feedback on a
vu pas mal de choses dans l'entreprise
parmi ces parmi ses trouvailles une
entreprise à dubaï avait créé sa propre
entre sa propre application
parmi les fonctionnalités de cette
application on pouvait donner un
feedback anonyme et spontanée à ses
collègues à n'importe quel moment je
pouvais décider sur l'application de
faire un retour sur le travail d'un
collègue sur la gestion d'un projet sur
le fonctionnement global de l'entreprise
de façon anonyme
cette entreprise c'est l' agence
dubaïote d'omnicom media group une
entreprise qui compte plus de 70000
personnes à travers le monde
omnicom media group a fait le choix de
faire d'envoyer des feedbacks de manière
anonyme
al'inverse on était aux états unis
aventura où on a rencontré on a visité
l'entreprise patagonia patagonia a
choisi quelque chose de tout à fait
différent chez patagonia vous n'aurez
pas de feedback si vous ne le demandez
pas un cercle de confiance
là où les feedbacks et est envoyé chez
patagonia ils sont reçus aussi omnicom
media group a fait le choix d'un
feedback
anonyme je sais patagonia les feedbacks
sont faits en face à face
on voit donc qu'il existe deux modèles
différents dans deux entreprises
différentes dans des cadres culturels et
géographiques totalement différent
toutefois on peut pas dire qu'il ya une
solution qui marche mieux qu'une autre
le feedback d'omnicom media group marche
dans leur contexte
à dubaï celui de patagonia est une
réussite aventura aux états unis
patagonia est une entreprise aussi
reconnu pour l'autre
ce mission de sa mission de sa vision la
mission de patagonia c'est de créer les
meilleurs produits possibles causant le
moindre impact sur l'environnement mais
aussi d'utiliser le monde des affaires
pour inspirer et trouver des solutions
face à la crise environnementale avec
hugo lorsqu'on a eu l'occasion
d'échanger de discuter avec les employés
de patagonia on a été réellement frappé
par leur engagement par leurs
convictions
il était sincèrement convaincu que le
travail qu'ils réalisent et avait un
sens c'était beau à voir
je me souviendrai toujours de cheaters
de crise qui aurait pu nous parler
pendant des heures de patagonia son
histoire son engagement leur engagement
pour cette mission d'ailleurs sheepers
nous a même agité aller surfer avec lui
pour apprendre en effet et oui chez g
patagonia votre manager ne peut pas vous
refuser le droit d'aller surfer si les
vagues sont bonnes concrètement comment
on peut s'assurer que ce que fait
l'entreprise
la mission de l'entreprise la vision
qu'elle transmet et respecté dans les
actions de tous les jours je sais
patagonia il existe une équipe qui est
dédié à cela
cette équipe va dire si telle ou telle
action tel ou tel produit respecte les
normes que patagonia s'est fixé c'est ce
que palau haïti à singapour appels sont
ethical lab là aussi un groupe
d'employés statut si oui ou non un
contrat respecte les valeurs de
l'entreprise
ainsi jamais un employé n'aura à
travailler pour un client qui est en
désaccord avec ses convictions
l'entreprise a donc des employés motivés
engagé et qui illustre aux fidèles très
bien tous ces entreprises utilisent des
outils différents
ces outils peuvent concerner le cadre de
travail
la mission de l'entreprise la
rémunération le feed back comme on l'a
vu ou encore la reconnaissance
si tous ces outils tous ces méthodes
toutes ces pratiques constituent
l'identité propre de l'entreprise
ce qu'on peut appeler sa culture on a vu
des cultures de tous types d entreprises
de tous types dans tout pays de toutes
tailles aussi ces entreprises n'ont
absolument rien aux commandes à première
vue
et pourtant et pourtant quelque chose
les relie il existe une unité dans ces
entreprises
ces entreprises ont misé sur l'homme sur
le collaborateur sur la personne et en
misant sur cela elles ont réussi à être
productive créative et à retenir ses
talents qu'il constitue l'entreprise
après tout l'entreprise de demain celle
dans laquelle travaille la pierre est ce
que ce ne serait pas une entreprise sur
mesure et qu'est ce qu'on entend
justement par entreprise sur mesure une
entreprise sur mesure ce serait pour
hugo et moi une entreprise dans laquelle
qui et qui parvient à engager ses
collaborateurs ses employés
ceux là même qui ont les moyens de
devenir plus créatifs de devenir plus
productifs et ses employés qui feront
aussi en sorte que l'entreprise se
réinvente en permanence une entreprise
sur mesure c'est donc une entreprise sur
mesure pour les collaborateurs
une entreprise qui sait transmettre une
vision et faire en sorte que cette
vision soit respectée dans l'action de
tous les jours l'entreprise sur mesure
c'est aussi une entreprise sur mesure
pour ses collaborateurs une entreprise
qui est porté par ses collaborateurs et
qui s'assure que tous les jours ces
mêmes collaborateurs ont la possibilité
de créer les outils pour développer
cette entreprise
enfin une entreprise sur mesure c'est
une entreprise qui est capable d'évoluer
de s'adapter au contexte avec tous les
employés qui la constitue à notre tour
on s'est donc empressé de dire à pierre
que oui cette entreprise sur mesure
existe elle existe on en a vu sur cinq
continents alors si elle existe il reste
plus qu'à pierre vous françois ou moi
d'être acteurs de cette grande
transformation qui est en jeu aux quatre
coins du monde
merci
[Applaudissements]